[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend es geht um die rettung der
menschheit nichts weniger an solchen
appellen vor dem g20 gipfel und der
weltklimakonferenz mangelt es nicht ob
aber die weltgemeinschaft die kraft
haben wird den kampf gegen den
klimawandel wirksam zu beschleunigen ist
heute offen dieser tag vor gipfelbeginn
in rom war diplomatisches warmlaufen vor
allem us präsident biden hatte ein
volles programm und machte als erst
zweiter katholischer präsident der usa
nach kennedy auch dem papst seine
aufwartung rom zwischen audienzen und
protesten andreas postel berichtet
sie wollen sich gehör verschaffen bei
den mächtigen dieser welt beim club der
g20 der sich in ihrer stadt trifft denn
es geht um ihre zukunft genau handelt
jetzt mit ihrem pappschild protestiert
auch greta für mehr klimaschutz und
gerechtigkeit
wir werden hier unsere zukunft kämpfen
weil es die einzige es die wir haben und
wir werden nicht zulassen dass man sie
uns nimmt wegen der zu erwartenden
proteste sind hier in der stadt seit
tagen die sicherheitskräfte in höchste
alarmbereitschaft auch am trevi brunnen
wo das gruppenbild der staats und
regierungschefs entstehen soll für ihren
friedlichen protest hat greta einen
starken verbündeten im vatikan der
unermüdlich mahnt die schöpfung zu
bewahren und der am tag vor dem großen
gipfel in rom den amerikanischen
präsidenten empfängt begegnung zweier
liberaler katholiken die von einer
gewissen spannung überschattet ist der
konservative bischöfe in den usa joe
biden massiv angreifen wegen seiner
liberalen haltung zur abtreibung
auf der tagesordnung stand das thema
heute nicht aber die kommunion werde er
ihm deshalb nicht verweigern so pabst
franziskus als zeichen der zuneigung
macht ihm joe biden ein sehr
persönliches geschenk die commander
münze seines verstorbenen sohnes
franziskus sei der größte krieger des
friedens den er je getroffen habe nach
den ruppigen auftritten donald trumps so
die hoffnung kommt mit us präsident joe
biden mehr gemeinsames handeln auf die
weltbühne zurück doch nachdem
afghanistan debakel und dem u-boot
streit mit frankreich ist er sichtlich
bemüht die verstimmungen im 3
atlantischen verhältnis haus zu räumen
neben dem globalen kampf gegen die
pandemie will europa treiber seien beim
klimaschutz die g 20 nationen sind
verantwortlich für 80 prozent der
treibhausgasemissionen
das heißt wir müssen jetzt ehrgeizige
ziele setzen und setzen wir müssen pläne
vorlegen wie wir sie erreichen wollen
wir müssen die 100 milliarden auf die
beine bringen die für die
entwicklungsländer so wichtig sind im
kampf gegen den klimawandel
doch beim geld hört die freundschaft
meistens auf das weiß der noch
finanzminister ganz genau olaf scholz
wird die bundeskanzlerin auf dem gipfel
auch bei den bilateralen treffen
begleiten viele länder auf der welt
gucken darauf was in deutschland
geschieht sie wollen dass es so
ist dass man sich auf deutschland
verlassen kann in der eu in der nato in
den internationalen zusammenarbeit
strukturen wie bei g7 und g20 und
deshalb ist es ein gutes kontinuität
signal dass die kanzlerin und auch hier
gemeinsam mit den anderen ländern
sprechen können und sicherstellen können
dass alle sich auch weiter auf
deutschland verlassen g20 gastgeber
italien kann zumindest ein
erfolgsergebnis bereits vorweisen die
globale mindeststeuer soll morgen auf
dem g-20-gipfel feierlich beschlossen
werden anders als joe biden wird
gastgeber mario draghi die präsidenten
chinas und russlands dabei nicht
persönlich begrüßen können sie werden
sich nur aus der ferne per video
konferenz zu schalten damit sind die
vorzeichen nicht gerade die besten dass
greta und ihre jungen mitstreiterinnen
am ende kraftvolle beschlüsse auf dem g
20 gipfel in rom erleben werden
ja dann fragen wir danach den gipfel in
rom verfolgt anne gellinek eine das
thema klima ganz oben auf der agenda
aber wird denn überhaupt konkret etwas
dabei heraus kommen
tja die verhandlungen der sherpas über
die klimaziele im abschlussdokument die
laufen noch und sie gestalten sich
offenbar ziemlich schwierig denn die
ausgangsposition der g 20 länder sind
natürlich total unterschiedlich da ist
der amerikanische präsident joe biden
der hier geschwächt ankommt weil er
nicht sicher sein kann dass er seine
eigene klimapolitik zu hause durchsetzen
kann er trifft auf die ehrgeizigen
klimaziele der europäer und auf länder
wie china und indien die am liebsten gar
keine reduktionsziele oder jahreszahlen
in dem abschlussdokument sehen würden
zusätzlich erschwert werden die
verhandlungen dadurch dass von 20 staats
und regierungschefs eben fünf wegen der
pandemie nicht anreisen darunter wir
haben es gehört der chinesische und der
russische präsident und insofern die g20
würden sich gerne als vorreiter der
klimapolitik hier feiern aber ob das
dieses wochenende gelingt ist ist ist
offen für angela merkel ist es aller
voraussicht nach der abschied von der
gipfel bühne nach 16 jahren im amt das
wird besonders beobachtet werden und vor
allem auch ihr begleiter oder
ihr angela merkel weiß das natürlich und
sie hat dafür gesorgt dass es auch was
zu beobachten gibt denn sie tritt hier
auf dem
g-20-gipfel im doppelpack mit nachfolger
auf olaf scholz ist zwar als
finanzminister angereist aber er bekommt
hier sozusagen das volle kanzler
programm angela merkel nimmt ihn mit zum
bilateralen treffen mit dem us
präsidenten joe biden morgen zum
gespräch mit dem türkischen präsidenten
und sogar zu einer viererrunde mit joe
biden boris johnson und emmanuel laurent
zur iran strategie die botschaft dieses
doppelpacks ist klar die deutsche
außenpolitik ist verlässlich es wird
keine großen sprünge geben und
vermutlich sendet die kanzlerin auch
noch einen kleinen gruß an die
autokratischen herrschaften im g20 club
an die herren putin und den pinien china
seht her so ein machtwechsel der kann
ganz demokratisch schmerzfrei und
zivilisiert ablaufen dankeschön anne
gellinek nach rom ja olaf scholz nahm
heute in rom schon am treffen der
g-20-finanzminister teil doch die
deutsche innenpolitik verfolgte ihn
genau genommen die frage ob er nun den
parteivorsitz seiner spd anstrebe der
posten wird geräumt und diesmal ganz
freiwillig was für die spd ja zuletzt
nicht die regel war norbert walter
borjans
69 will nicht wieder antreten als co-
parteichef sondern das feld jüngeren
überlassen aus berlin karl hinterleitner
verwandelt hieß das motto des großen ig
metall aktionstags heute in berlin und
norbert walter borjans wusste bei seinem
auftritt bereits dass auch er einen
wandel plant im dezember gibt er das amt
des parteivorsitzenden ab das sagte
dennoch spd chef in einem
zeitungsinterview
erreicht
das ist wirklich auch fortgesetzt wird
fortgesetzt werden soll das auf kurs
bringen der spd walter borjans sieht
nach gut zwei jahren im amt seine
aufgabe als erfüllt an in der partei
respekt vor der entscheidung
ich bin überzeugt dass norbert walter
borjans diese entscheidung gut für sich
abgewogen hat mit freunden vielleicht
auch darüber gesprochen hat aber der
bundesparteitag steht bevor wo eine
wiederwahl angestanden hätte ich bedaure
das aber ich habe auch verständnis für
seine beweggründe offen bleibt was mit
der co vorsitzenden saskia esken
passiert bleibt sie wird sie ersetzt
gibt es in zukunft überhaupt noch die
doppelspitze und wie stabil ist der
mühsam erreichte ausgleich zwischen dem
linken und dem konservativen flügel der
partei ich bin ganz sicher die ganz
unterschiedlichen interessen werden in
einem großen parteivorstand auch zu wort
und letztlich eben auch zu einer
kandidatur kommen
generalsekretär lars klingbeil wird als
möglicher kandidat hoch gehandelt
nachdem olaf scholz heute klargestellt
hat dass er kanzler aber nicht
parteivorsitzender werden will die spd
wird gemeinsam entscheiden wie das dann
weitergeht das ist keine schwierige
aufgabe klar ist aber auch dass ich mich
auf das konzentrieren wofür ich von den
bürgerinnen bürgern auftrag bekommen
habe nämlich eine regierung zu bilden
und der nächste kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland zu werden
häufiger nicht vermieden werden dass er
sehr klar ausgedrückt der geordnete
rückzug von norbert walter borjans gibt
der spd genug zeit die nachfolge zu
regeln entschieden wird beim parteitag
am 11 dezember bis dahin ist der posten
frei wir fragen nach bei theo koll in
berlin olaf scholz sagt er wolle sich
darauf konzentrieren kanzler zu werden
aber muss er nicht um ein starker
kanzler zu werden auch nach dem
parteivorsitz greifen ja also wenn er
die lektionen der geschichte ernst nimmt
dann müsste er das denn nur die
verbindung von kanzlerschaft und
parteivorsitz schafft die größtmögliche
stabilität der macht alles andere
beinhaltet das risiko einer entfremdung
zwischen kanzler und partei das hat
helmut schmidt so erlebt das hat der
späte gerhard schröder erlebt oder auch
jetzt angela merkel aktuelles olaf
scholz in der spd natürlich komplett
unumstrittene hat die partei zu einem
lange ja kaum für möglich gehaltenen
wahlsieg geführt das macht ihn mächtig
aber
man darf nicht vergessen dass scholz bei
der wahl zum parteivorsitzenden vor zwei
jahren nicht gewählt wurde also er ist
nicht gerade der natürliche liebling der
partei das ist momentan zwar kein
problem aber sobald er als kanzler bei
der spd unpopuläre ampel politik
umsetzen muss dann könnte sich das mit
der zeit für ihn zu einem macht problem
entwickeln
auch die cdu sucht einen neuen
parteivorsitzenden da gibt es nun morgen
in berlin eine große
kreisvorsitzendenkonferenz
wird die schon eine vorentscheidung
bringen ich glaube ich das ist morgen
kein beschlussgremium sondern eher eine
art
blutdruckmesser der basis das treffen
sich ja die über 320 kreisvorsitzende
der cdu die ziemlich genau wissen was
die parteimitglieder vor ort wirklich
wollen und offensichtlich wollen viele
gefragt werden bei der auswahl des
nächsten parteivorsitzenden und fordern
deshalb eine mitgliederbefragung auch
wenn die eigentlich gar nicht vorgesehen
ist und formal ja nur der parteitag über
den chefposten entscheiden darf diese
verfahrensfrage ist aber auch deshalb so
wichtig weil die einfachen
parteimitglieder andere favoriten haben
als die delegierten friedrich merz
beispielsweise ist ja auf dem parteitag
schon zweimal durchgefallen und würde
dort auch nicht wieder antreten hat er
gesagt bisher hat sich noch kein
entschuldigung kein kandidat offen
gemeldet aber die morgige stimmung bei
den kreisvorsitzenden könnte ein hinweis
sein wer sich welche chancen ausrechnen
darf wir werden darauf achten ganz
vielen dank theo koll nach berlin so und
zur stimmung unter den kreisvorsitzenden
später mehr im heute-journal update mit
wulf schmiese im gespräch der
bundestagsabgeordnete thomas heilmann
der den berliner wahlkreis steglitz
zehlendorfer tritt ja zunächst weitere
nachrichten stunde lang aus auf ihrer
reise zum g20 gipfel in rom besuchte die
scheidende bundeskanzlerin merkel heute
auch griechenland in athen gestand sie
ein ihr sei bewusst gewesen welche
herausforderungen sie in der schweren
finanzkrise den griechen zugemutet hatte
merkel stand 2012 für den strengen
sparkurs den athen zur krisenbewältigung
umsetzen musste bei dem anderen großen
thema der migration warb merkel für den
dialog mit der türkei die fast vier
millionen flüchtlinge aufgenommen habe
das robert koch institut hat seit anfang
februar rund
118.000 impft durchbrüche registriert
die zunahme von corona infektionen trotz
vollständiger impfung sei erwartbar so
dass er kein ii da sich das virus
derzeit wieder verstärkt ausbreiten die
impf durchbrüche machten aber nur einen
geringen anteil an der gesamtzahl der
infizierten aus erklären experten und
dringend zugleich auf
auffrischimpfungen die aktuellen zahlen
das rk e mail at 24
1668 neuinfektionen innerhalb des tages
das sind
5096 mehr als vor einer woche
121 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage inzidenz ist auf
139,2 gestiegen in den usa können nun
auch kinder zwischen fünf und elf jahren
den corona impfstoff von far beyond act
pfizer erhalten die arzneimittelbehörde
fg folgte der empfehlung eines
expertengremiums und erteilte die
notfall zulassung damit kann die
impfkampagne für die etwa 28 millionen
betroffenen kinder in den usa im
november starten auch in europa hat
biontech weise eine zulassung für kinder
dieser altersgruppe beantragt im justiz
streit mit polen hat das europaparlament
die eu kommission wegen untätigkeit vor
dem europäischen gerichtshof verklagt
parlamentspräsident sony erklärte die
klage solle die kommission zum handeln
veranlassen die eu behörde unter leitung
von präsidentin von der leyen habe nicht
alle rechtlichen mittel ausgeschöpft um
polen zur änderung seiner umstrittenen
justizreform zu zwingen das polnische
parlament hat den bau einer befestigten
anlage an der grenze zum benachbarten
belarus genehmigt reaktion auf die
illegalen grenzübertritte über die route
gelangen auch immer mehr migranten nach
deutschland
bei görlitz nahe der polnischen grenze
entdeckte die polizei einen toten
flüchtling in einem kleintransporter der
32 jährige iraker war offenbar mit 30
weiteren menschen eingeschleust worden
die auch von deutschland geforderte
ausweisung neuer meeresschutzgebiete in
der antarktis ist erneut gescheitert wie
in den letzten fünf jahren stemmten sich
china und russland weil der konferenz
der antarktis kommission gegen
entsprechende pläne es geht um 1 4
millionen quadratkilometer großes gebiet
in der ostantarktis auf der
antarktischen halbinsel und im
artenreichen weddell meer
ein schutzgebiet dort könnte
umweltexperten zur folge der
erderwärmung entgegen wirken und zum
erhalt einer funktionierenden
biodiversität beitragen
ja diese meldung zeigt wie schwer ist es
globalen klimaschutz zu erreichen immer
sind wirtschaftliche interessen im spiel
was für die antarktis gilt gilt auch für
die nordpol region durch die erwärmung
des wassers hat sich die eisdecke in den
letzten 40 jahren um rund die hälfte
reduziert
mit dem klimawandel gerät auch das
ökosystem aus den fugen das ist im hohen
norden russland zu beobachten wo die
böden eigentlich permanent gefroren sind
wenn dieser permafrost abtaut heizt er
die erderwärmung noch zusätzlich an ein
teufelskreis den vögeln beschreibt
es plätschert in immer tieferen
erdschichten taut der permafrostboden
de jahre alte knochen die vergangenheit
frei und nimmt dabei einfluss auf die
zukunft des klimas
ein team des max planck instituts auf
spurensuche in der russischen arktis
klar ist nur dass sich dieses ökosystem
extrem ändern wird und jetzt gerade was
den klimawandel angeht wird das eben
voraussichtlich auch bedeuten dass mehr
kohlenstoff aus dem derzeitigen firma
festspeicher freigesetzt werden wird vor
zwei jahren begleiten wir die
wissenschaftler an der ostsibirischen
küste hier messen sie die konzentration
von treibhausgasen
umgeben von dauerfrostböden und sonst
nicht viel mehr und doch von globaler
bedeutung
denn 25 prozent der landmasse auf der
nordhalbkugel sind permafrostböden wie
in einer tiefkühltruhe lagern hier
pflanzenreste tierkadaver kurz
kohlenstoffe schauen sie auf werden sie
zersetzt geraten co2 und methan in die
atmosphäre wo sie die klimaerwärmung
weiter anheizen ihre daten dazu seien
eindeutig so matthias göcke heute
man sich stabile phasen im jahr ansieht
wie zum beispiel die winter
konzentration wo halt aufgrund der
heißen schneebedeckung die signale recht
stabil aussehen da sieht man schon dass
jedes jahr für jahr eigentlich ein
höheres niveau zum beispiel an den
methankonzentrationen derartigen
atmosphäre erreicht werden das ist in
sibirien diesen sommer brannte länger
und großflächiger als jemals zuvor
aufgezeichnetes nicht nur folge des
klimawandels sondern auch eine neue
gefahr für die permafrostböden es gibt
eine organische auflage die sind ein
bisschen wie so eine isolierschicht für
den permafrostboden darunter fungieren
und wenn man die jetzt weg brennt dann
kann es sein dass sich der das system
also komplett de stabilisiert in sehr
kurzer zeit in russland das zu fast zwei
dritteln auf permafrost steht schwimmen
fundamente weg sagten pipelines ab erst
im juni letzten jahres treiben über 20
tonnen diesel durch die arktis weil der
boden unter einem tank wegtaut
diese katastrophe von no reason sind
vermutlich mit den veränderungen im
klima verbunden und ich denke das macht
unsere regierung angst
und so stellt einer der lange jahre den
klimawandel lloyd mitte nun in aussicht
sein land wolle bis 2060 co2 neutral
werden lupe
jede geopolitische wissenschaftliche
technische oder ideologische rivalität
verliert unter diesen umständen ihre
bedeutung weil der gewinner wieder luft
zum atmen noch wasser zu treten hätte
den großen worten ist bisher kein
nachvollziehbarer plan gefolgt
unterdessen bestärken sich tausende
böden und die erderwärmung gegenseitig
ein kreislauf von dem nicht klar ist wie
lange er noch zu stoppen wäre
und nun nachrichten aus der wirtschaft
gundula gause
trotz voller auftragsbücher müssen
unternehmen wegen der materialknappheit
und lieferproblemen die produktion
drosseln die gemengelage einer der
anlässe für die gewerkschaften alarm zu
schlagen die ig metall rief zu einem
aktionstag in berlin kam wie gesehen
norbert walter borjans valerie haller
bundesweit waren es rund 50.000
gewerkschafter die demonstrierten mit
welchen konkreten
forderungen da bist du die
gewerkschaften sagen der weg zur
klimaneutralität aber eben auch die
zunehmende digitalisierung bedeuten
einen riesigen umbruch in wirtschaft und
gesellschaft sie fürchten dass viele
jobs auf dem spiel stehen und fordern
einen sozialverträglichen umbau aber
auch investitionen in milliarden höhe
dafür sind sie heute auf die straße
gegangen laut ig metall zehntausende in
über 50 städten auch am opel-werk
eisenach demonstrierten sie wie chips
fehlen geht hier im werk seit wochen gar
nichts mehr die opelaner verunsichert
auch weil mutterkonzerns de landes plant
die werke eisenach und rüsselsheim aus
dem opel verbund zu lösen mit schwer
absehbaren folgen opel steht wie andere
auch vor einem tiefgreifenden wandel
ich glaube dass tatsächlich das thema
produktion von fahrzeugen nicht mehr die
große kernkompetenz der
automobilindustrie der zukunft sein wird
es geht darum sozusagen um das thema
entwicklung von software für autonomes
fahren von
elektromobilität opel ist nur eines von
vielen industrieunternehmen die schon
mittendrin stecken oder den noch ein
massiver umbau bevor steht das gilt für
die autobranche für zulieferer start
hersteller die chemische industrie bei
vielen mitarbeitern wächst die sorge
dass die zukunft ohne sie stattfindet so
war der aktionstag der gewerkschaften
heute ein weckruf von dem sie hoffen
dass er auch von den koalitionären in
berlin gehört wird vielen dank valerie
nach frankfurt eine meldung vom sport
tennis spieler alexander zverev hat beim
atp-turnier in wien das halbfinale
erreicht der 24 jährige hamburger
besiegte im viertelfinale den kanadier
felix oder alias ihm nach hartem kampf
mit 6 4 3 6 und 6 3 in der runde der
letzten vier wartet auf zverev nun das
ungesetzte spanische top talent carlos
alcaraz
der blick auf die erde den blauen
planeten wunderschön und unter der
dünnen atmosphäre auch verwundbar diesen
blick kann matthias maurer ab sonntag
genießen der zweite deutsche
esa-astronaut startet dann zur weltraum
mission cosmic cas ein halbes jahr wird
er auf der weltraumstation iss
verbringen mit unzähligen experimenten
innen und außen am sonntag 7 uhr 21 geht
es in einer space extrakte los vom
weltraumbahnhof cape canaveral aber
aufgeregt wirkt für unser neuer mann im
all heute nicht susanne freitag
guck mal da alan shepard er ist stolz
auf dieses bild von amerikas erster mann
im all dem fünften menschen auf dem mond
für rusty steht da der rusty fischer ist
in cape canaveral auch einer raumfahrt
legende
hier haben sich astronauten und
kosmonauten immer getroffen und
natürlich hat er den erster amerikaner
ins all fliegen sehen
das war 1961 als alan shepard hohfluh da
war ich auf der highschool vor dem start
haben wir alle radio gehört
und dann ging es los wir sind alle raus
gegangen um diesen staat zu sehen
matthias maurer war noch nicht bei rusty
geht auch gar nicht da ist in quarantäne
und wurde heute morgen hierher
zugeschaltet letzte fragen vor dem flug
der doktor der materialwissenschaften
wird auf der iss mehr als 100
experimente durchführen unterstützt wird
er von zahlreichen wissenschaftlern auf
der erde mein anteil ist eigentlich der
leichteste ich muss nur ein stundenplan
aufmachen reinschauen und dann steht
dort wirklich genau beschrieben wie ein
experiment aufbauen muss welche kabel
verbinden muss und wenn ich ein problem
habe oder dass nicht verstehe dann kann
ich runter punkten und dann ist auf dem
boden immer ein experte für mich da der
mich unterstützt der astronauten job
vielfältig ein mensch und gesundheit ist
das größte feld wir haben fluid physik
wir haben astronomie wir haben
chemie biologie strahlen oder dosimetrie
halter oben können wir versuche machen
die hier am erdboden gar nicht denkbar
sind gar nicht möglich in einem labor
werden wir da oben eben permanent
schwerelosigkeit haben und bedingungen
die wir hier unten nicht so einfach
herstellen können maurer wird einen
europäischen roboterarm in betrieb
nehmen testen ob besondere oberflächen
bakterien abweisen können beton
herstellen in 400 kilometer höhe nervös
wir sind alle extrem ruhig ganz
entspannt und ich muss mich da jeden tag
kneifen weil ich denke ja so ein
ereignis da hätte ich mehr erwartet dass
ich total hibbelig und nervös bin und
ich denke die aufregung wird dann
spätestens einsetzen mit ihrer rakete
gezündet werden sie werden ins all
bringen eine crew dragon rakete von
spacex dem unternehmen von milliardär
elon musk
das da ist alles von ihnen muss erklärt
und raste auf seiner terrasse da auf dem
schwarzen dingen landen immer die hilfs
raketen
der staat wird genau da hinten sein und
er wird natürlich zugucken wie immer
ganz entspannt so viel von uns hier
folgt jetzt direkt das politbarometer
das unter anderem zeigt mit steigenden
infektionszahlen wächst auch die sorge
der menschen vor dem nächsten corona
winter wir geben ab an matthias vorne
[Musik]
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer
das ist sowohl die vierte welle die
korona lage im land verschlechtert sich
jedenfalls täglich fast 25.000
gemeldeten neuinfektionen heute auch die
inzidenz steigt rasant und die
krankenhäuser kommen wieder unter druck
das öffentliche leben aber läuft fast
normal weiter einige bundesländer
verzichten sogar auf die masken pflicht
in schulen bars und diskotheken dürfen
öffnen auch große veranstaltungen in
innenräumen sind erlaubt in dieser
situation machen sich viele deutsche
sorgen um die eigene gesundheit
47 prozent halten sich durch das corona
virus für gefährdet das sind deutlich
mehr als anfang des monats da gaben 31
prozent der befragten an sich um ihre
gesundheit zu sorgen
eine klare mehrheit bewertet die
geltenden corona maßnahmen als gerade
richtig doch jeder fünfte deutsche
findet inzwischen sie müssten härter
ausfallen deutlich mehr als vor vier
wochen sollten die fallzahlen weiter
steigen möchte fast ein drittel der
befragten stärkere einschränkungen für
alle im öffentlichen leben 43 prozent
wollen dass nur für ungeimpfte und wie
stehen die befragten zu einer
impfpflicht
wer im gesundheitswesen arbeitet muss
sich impfen lassen finden fast drei
viertel der befragten für lehrer und
kita personal fordern 64 prozent eine
impfpflicht
auch wenn jeder zweite glaubt dass es in
den krankenhäusern nicht wieder zu
ähnlich hohen belastungen kommen wird
wie in vorangegangenen corona wellen die
sorge der deutschen vor corona wächst
zu einem anderen thema die energiepreise
schießen nach oben fast zwei drittel der
befragten im politbarometer sehen darin
für sich selbst ein großes oder sogar
sehr großes problem
dementsprechend finden 77 prozent einen
staatlichen zuschuss für bürgerinnen und
bürger mit geringem einkommen gut 20
prozent wollen das nicht
eine von vielen fragen die eine neue
regierung beschäftigen wird seit
mittwoch arbeiten die potenziellen
partner in 22 arbeitsgruppen einen
koalitionsvertrag für eine ampel
regierung aus vieles ist noch offen
manches umstrittenen über einiges
herrscht schon einigkeit dass ein
bündnis aus spd grünen und fdp viel
beitragen wird zur lösung der probleme
im land glauben 54 prozent der befragten
42 prozent bezweifeln das bei den
anhängern von fdp und union ist die
skepsis wie zu erwarten am größten
vieles von dem was sich die möglichen
ampel regierung zur lösung der probleme
vorgenommen hat investitionen in
digitale infrastruktur etwa bekämpfung
des klimawandels oder die förderung des
wohnungsbaus wird teuer deshalb sind
sich 92 prozent der deutschen sicher
dass das ohne neue schulden nicht zu
schaffen ist
in der projektion zeigt sich in dieser
woche wenig bewegung
wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme
die spd auf 27 prozent minus 1 cdu/csu
lägen bei 20 prozent plus 1 die grünen
bei 16 prozent minus 1 die fdp 14 plus 1
die afg 11 die linke 5 prozent beide
unverändert
zu unserer top ten der wichtigsten
politiker auf der skala von 5
bewertet nach sympathie und leistung
bleibt armin laschet schlusslicht minus
1,1 verbessert davor jens spahn mit
minus 0,2 leicht schlechter friedrich
merz minus 0,1 verbessert annalena
baerbock 0,2 schlechter platz sechs für
markus söder 0,4 etwas schlechter
christian lindner verbessert auf 1,1
robert habeck 1,6 etwas schlechter auf
platz 3 manuela schwesig 1,6 platz zwei
für olaf scholz 1,8 beide mit verlusten
ganz vorne weiterhin angela merkel mit
2,4 etwas besser
die kanzlerin und ihr kabinett haben
diese woche von bundespräsident
steinmeier ihre entlassungsurkunden
erhalten die alte regierung ist jetzt
nur noch geschäftsführend im amt die
mögliche neue hat sich selbst zur
fortschritts koalition erklärt und will
einiges anders machen als die vorgänger
im gespräch ist auch den besitz und
verbrauch kleiner mengen cannabis zu
legalisieren
das findet eine mehrheit von 53 prozent
richtig 40 prozent finden es falsch der
plan findet parteiübergreifend
zustimmung mehrheitlich dagegen sind nur
die anhänger von cdu/csu
der kampfruf der cannabis befürworter
legalize it könnte also mit der ampel
wirklichkeit werden
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute app wie oft zdf
heute.de
wie die repräsentativen umfragen der
forschungsgruppe wahlen zustande kommen
informationen zur methodik und zu den
qualitätsstandards finden sie unter
politbarometer punkt zdf.de vielen dank
für ihr interesse das nächste
politbarometer gibt es dann am 12
november
und nach dem wetter geht's hier gleich
weiter mit der heute-show ihnen noch
einen entspannten abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon guten abend zu und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter in glasgow beginnt
am montag die 26 weltklimakonferenz
dabei geht es vor allem um die frage wie
können wir die erhitzung des planeten
begrenzen unser größtes problem ist der
co2 ausstoß kohlendioxid ist eigentlich
ganz natürlich in der atmosphäre
vorhanden pflanzen ozeane und böden
setzen co2 frei gleichzeitig nehmen sie
aber die gleiche menge auf ein stabiler
kreislauf den der mensch andauern stört
denn durch verbrennen von kohle öl und
gas bringen wir jedes jahr zusätzlich
co2 in die atmosphäre
ein großer anteil verbleibt für viele
hundert jahre in der atmosphäre und
lässt die temperatur weiter steigen
deswegen ist es wichtig so rasch wie
möglich die emissionen zu reduzieren
kommen wir zu den anderen parametern und
zum wetter zb mit dem regen aus dem
westen der uns in der nacht erreicht
ansonsten gibt es viele wolken nach
norden im osten klar dass auf wo die
sterne zeigen sich nach südosten hin zum
beispiel richtung donau bildet sich
nebel hier temperaturen bis minus zwei
grad und dann müssen sie örtlich mit
reifglätte rechnen deutlich milder ganz
im westen zum beispiel am niederrhein
bei elf grad kommentars verlauf kommen
die wolken weiter ins landesinnere von
westen her ist kann mal kräftiger regnen
ansonsten im osten viel sonnenschein im
südosten nach nebelauflösung sonne an
den alpen gibt es fühlen und das bei
temperaturen bis 18 grad an den alpen 10
grad in der eifel ja die nächsten tage
werden dann durchwachsen seien am
sonntag einige schauer bei 14 bis 20
grad und montag deutlich mehr vor allem
im süden ein schöner amt